i don't think we've met nicely no this
is really special for me
i and i hope this isn't creepy to admit
right off the bat but i had a
debilitating crush on you in high school
so that's i'll take that yeah that is
not i'm
i'm yeah i'm very happy about that
that's nice
who who was she was unreasonable though
why was it unreasonable i just i was
very young but i had these very intense
romantic feelings for you
i had like a vision board in my bedroom
you know what that is it's like pictures
of things you like and or want and mine
was like home alone two lost in new york
claire danes
destiny's child and then you
that's nice i like that i think i'm in
good company there
i think so yeah i had i mean i had two
huge celebrity crushes it was you and
macaulay culkin
really i love that
that's so cool oh yeah just the two
pillars of masculinity
yeah i can see there you were working a
certain theme there
you're the only two famous men i cared
about so in my head you guys like knew
each other and hung out all the time
which we did
uh i'm just curiou like you're you're
very funny your sister
is a writer you've done so well in
comedy your sister's a writer on new
girl so it feels like it's in the family
that you guys
are funny are your parents funny uh my
parents are
very funny it's not usually intentional
yeah but um yeah we i was born in iran
we moved here when i was really little
and i think anyone with immigrant
parents can probably
this is so distracting this outfit right
now
like i'm just so taken out of it yeah
that's all right
[Applause]
um what was i talking about i don't know
we're talking about it yeah they're not
intentionally funny and they're from
they're from iran yeah from i was born
there and i think anyone with immigrant
parents can relate to this
it's like they can sometimes take
liberties with the english language
you know like if they find a word they
really like they sort of bang it like a
drum
like the older iranian men in my family
will use the word lamborghini to
describe anything that's remotely nice
my uncle will call me and be like nasty
we went to the most
beautiful house everything was
lamborghini level quality lamborghini
lamborghini kitchen lamborghini hallway
lamborghini coffee table
such a confusing adjective what if they
ever got a lamborghini what would they
say what if they got another really nice
car they'd have to be like
i got the most lamborghini bmw
ford probe yeah my deepest fear is that
he'll actually drive a lamborghini
someday
have a terrible time and just not know
how to describe things
after that he's done